well since 1987 our country has
recognized national girls and women in
sports day that is today
and it is a celebration to inspire other
girls and women to play and just be
active
bianca holman is live this morning with
reaction from a few of our great local
athletes hi bianca good morning
hey good morning alex so this is a day
to acknowledge the accomplishments
that women athletes have played
throughout the years and of course to
encourage girls to get
active starting at a young age and like
you said we've got some amazing female
athletes here in the valley we were able
to talk with one of them
you remember that the las vegas aces
they came to
las vegas in 2018 and they've been to
the wnba finals twice
we spoke with carolyn schwartz of the
las vegas aces about her love for the
sport and
influence of her active family she told
us
access to sports gets more challenging
for girls as they get older because
sports are often tied to a school team
the women in sports foundation reports
girls have at 1.3 million
fewer opportunities to play high school
sports than boys
it's really sad and it would be great if
we could find ways to continue to fund
these opportunities and
find opportunities especially as girls
get older into high school for them to
keep playing even if
they don't necessarily make this the the
school team
for sure so virtually there's going to
be a girls fest it's hosted by a women
in sports foundation it's going to be
streamed on their youtube page
lots of special guests there's going to
be some olympians on there and if you've
got a girl athlete in the house
be sure that they tune in we do have
that link on our website so go to eight
newsnow dot com to get that link and
also we want to highlight
just some recent news in the wnba they
were able to reach an agreement
to actually increase player compensation
and benefits so huge talk a huge thing
that is happening across
all aspects of when it comes to equality
reporting live bianca holman 8 news now